hector mejia is live in henderson
showing us how firefighters are
responding
to heat related emergencies good morning
hector
hey there sherry good morning we are at
the henderson fire department's training
center here taking a look at how
they respond to emergencies and what
happens when someone is
dealing with a heat-related injury or
some illness so we have uh some visuals
here to show you
we also have leslie hernandez to talk to
us about all right so when you guys rush
out to a call
uh what are the signs we should all look
out for before it really
even reaches that point so if you're
going to be outside for a
prolonged period of time you want to
make sure you're drinking enough water
staying cool
if you start feeling fatigued sweaty i'm
just a little bit overall tired maybe
it's time to get some shade and get some
water
who's at greater risk right now of uh
suffering from a heat related illness
definitely elderly but maybe people have
above 65 and children definitely we got
to make sure they're drinking water like
i said
staying cool staying hydrated so it's
been hot all week
what have you guys been seeing you know
so far um
you know what a lot of people forget to
drink water it's very common here
you aren't sweating so you feel like you
weren't thirsty but you have to remember
to stay cool and drink a lot of water
during the day
and when you're going through this
emergency what does your body typically
feel
i understand complete confusion some
dizziness
your skin kind of starts to change color
is that right um it
does and the symptoms vary just
depending on where you're at and what
stage
but if you're starting to feel very
sweaty
fatigued tired and you're not doing much
but you're outside
then those are definitely signs where
that you should get inside and start
cooling measures
so there's a lot of training that goes
on here tell us just a little bit about
what you guys do here when you
train and get ready to head out there to
the field so
we like to train we like to
train as if it was a real incident so
like i said we
earlier we wear our turnouts while we're
training out here
we'll do some training in the district
but
we like to make sure that we're
replicating what we're doing
on a call and that gear is really having
you train with it on
we do yes yeah yeah not only heavy but
also really hot yes very hot
but um it like it's good it's good for
us yeah all right thank you very much so